[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Juliet is
with us in Greenville South Carolina as
promised hi Juliet how can we
help well I wanted to ask your opinion
me and my husband last year had about
$250,000 and we invested at um in a CB
at a credit union and it has matured and
we're want wondering if we should go
back to the same um thing invested in
the CD and um are to look elsewhere and
we're we really don't want to take a
risk with the money so we're both 80
years old and we didn't feel like we
wanted to take a risk in the stock
market but we wanted your opinion of
what you thought we should do I would go
right back and renew that
CD you would yeah okay it doesn't pay
very much it's not a very good long-term
investment but it gives you a lot of
peace and you told me three times you
didn't want risk and I heard you and I
heard you okay okay okay so I'm 6 I'm
63 and I don't have any CDs all of mine
is invested in mutual funds in the stock
market but I'm comfortable with that
risk and I can tell by talking to you
that if you did that with your
250,000 you would be awake at night
scared you're probably exactly right and
the last thing I want to cause is a
sweet 80y old person to be awake at
night okay now let me ask you the second
question is any of these in do you think
that any of these investment
companies uh would their CDs pay more
than the credit union
they might but it's not enough to fool
with okay uh in other words what are you
getting on this CD what are they
offering you when you renew it well I
think um I think she said 5.5 that's not
bad at
all okay okay if you got if you got six
but you were dealing with people you
didn't know and trust like your credit
union again Yes again this is about
sleeping well at night and I wouldn't
lose I wouldn't go jumping around get a
half a percent more and lose
sleep right cuz you're very you're very
comfortable with this Credit Union and
the ncua does have a
$250,000 guarantee on this so you're
covered on your
guarantee and uh if the credit union
failed in other words like an FDIC but
the uh with a credit union it's not FDIC
it's called the ncua but anyway yeah
you're you're fine there I I personally
would just tell you to stay right
there okay that's what I wanted your
opinion
but you need but I I'll say it again for
the sake of our listeners that's not
because it's that 5 and a half% is a
great long-term investment because it's
really not it's because I want you to be
able to sleep and 5 and a half% is a
good CD and we're do talking about your
comfort here not about a 20-year
investment Horizon that's right okay so
if Juliet called she's 80 80 years old
and she says Dave we got $250,000 we
just C out the CD which what's the best
what would you do if you were us and she
wasn't fearful of the risk Juliet was
she was n you know again I appreciated
you taking care of her because yes we
don't want her to be stressed out but if
somebody is 80 years old with
$250,000 and they're not worried about
it as much what would you do at 80 years
old well with some of my investments at
63 it would also be more true at 880 I'm
I'm already realizing that some of the
investing I'm doing is not for me cuz
I'll never touch it yeah it's really for
the Next Generation yeah and so uh you
guys the Ramsey you know the Ramsey kids
are going to be getting this stuff and
so when I make an investment decision
now unless it's a five or a 10e horizon
if I'm buying something out there long
term I'm obviously thinking about you
know the Next Generation after I'm gone
and so uh you know if we're to
superimpose that on her situation if
you've got 250,000 you're putting it
into a CD that tells me you're not
living on it because that CD is not
paying you monthly so you don't need a
return on that so they've got other
money yeah that they're living on so
they very
likely uh unless they something comes up
and they need this money sure but they
very likely are doing their Investing
For The Next Generation at 80 years old
and so if you took that mindset it'd be
easy to put it in mutual funds because
you you might not be here 5 years but
you know the next generation will be
sure and you could they could leave it
alone just you know we're going to dump
250,000 in mutual funds and then when we
pass it'll pass to the kids yeah yeah
and you never you never touch it you're
not really investing for yourself at
that point yes okay so here's here's
what's funny I was telling you during
the break Winston and I sat with our
smart investor Pro this morning we do it
once a year and kind of like look at all
the Investments and uh I was actually
telling uh someone out in the lobby
Avery she's 15 and she was talking about
her Roth IRA mhm and I told her that uh
I looked at when when I started mine M
and when I started working for you guys
even in high school and all of it and
and as we're talking through all the
numbers and looking at everything you
know our investment Pro he was like okay
this is good you know here and here and
here and he's like and what's crazy is
what you guys are investing here you
probably won't touch it'll be for your
kids and so as you're saying this to me
your daughter you're investing money
that you won't touch I'm investing money
I probably won't touch and that you guys
is a family tree change like when we say
that what you're doing today when you
don't need the money to live or to do
the things you want to do yeah to to to
pass that on and when you give dignity
to your kids parents out there with
little ones and teach them to work and
and you know be able for them to live
out the principles on their own
regardless of what their parents are
doing and then they teach it to their
kids right it's just this big big Legacy
Snowball Effect that just keeps turning
over and over when everyone does their
part in each generation it just keeps it
going down the line I mean it's pretty
it's pretty remarkable and it's really
um encouraging out to you out there that
are on baby steps one two and three and
you're really grinding it out well and
if you blink you start to do this if you
blink it'll be 20 years cuz that Roth
IRA you did as a teenager is 20 years
old mhm and that money that you were
working and you know I felt a tax return
I paid the taxes on it and it was an
$800 initial investment Y and that
finally he pulled it up it was $800 that
that that was what your earned income
was that year yeah and that's what
you're allowed to report and I put that
in into a Roth and then the next year I
think it was probably 1,500 or something
or whatever I mean several years in a
row we did that with each of you as you
worked and uh but I mean 20 years later
yeah it's amazing what that becomes it's
great it's crazy create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life